foreign
Tech Independence is all about
the fact that I think the main sales
pitch of the cloud is now don't worry
your little head about that let us take
care of it we'll keep all of your data
see isn't that easier now there we've
got your data yeah and it actually
reminded me of something I think you
said in for our body about yoga studios
that no it's not the best thing for your
health but it's it's a better profitable
pitch for them to sell you a yoga studio
instead of the deadlift yeah free
weights yeah there's a lot of that in
Fitness overall for sure so there's an
incentive this is the tech equivalent of
that that I wish that history had gone
such a way that we all had our own
little private server at home but
instead the cloud made a better sales
pitch saying no no give us all your
stuff we'll take care of it forever so
my idea is if you spend a few hours to
learn how to do it yourself you'll just
have Tech Independence what that means
is self-reliance it gives you better
security better privacy better Freedom
better flexibility and total control and
I think it's a great use of your time to
spend a few hours learning to do this
kind of like somebody learning to drive
manual transmission right you don't need
to do it but this is a good life skill
to have especially imagine if we're in a
world that had more you know just 50
years ago or now in a lot of countries
you still can't drive automatic so have
you heard I don't know if you've heard
the same stories I have about how many
people have lost their Google accounts
there was a guy I know who's a very
Savvy Tech entrepreneur in Singapore who
because he was so tech savvy he put all
of his kids photos in the cloud since
the day his kid was born he put
everything onto Google photos for 10
years his kid was 10 years old the day
that he started a new company and said
I'm going to do the Google Apps for
business and it asked him a quick
question would you like to merge this
would your existing Gmail account he
said yes he merged it and the next day
his wife was like honey where are all
the photos of our kids they're in Google
photos she said no they're not and he
looked up he's like oh my God you mean
they're gone and he emailed customer
service and they said well no you chose
to merge your accounts and we warned you
that they only said well could you
please recover them they said no they're
gone this poor guy has no photos of his
kid from age zero to ten because he
trusted the clown I mean sorry Cloud you
can't show those clowns
the clowns and the clowns get the clown
text snark okay so do you do that on
purpose I did oh that was good yeah
anytime when somebody talks about the
cloud you can change it to an end
keep all my contacts in the clown
so everything I'm going to describe here
takes just a few hours to set up this
isn't a major major thing it's not that
hard listeners
of yours are used to being suggested to
learn how to do something and let me
also preface this first quick second
this is not a tangent by saying
I do not experience you maybe I'm
missing something maybe you have spider
holes dug in the backyard I do not
experience you to be a hyper paranoid
person at all so I just want to mention
that because folks might think oh my God
this guy's got like 20 years worth of
oatmeal and like you know gold bars and
guns in the basement and he's this guy
maybe right I want to sort of set the
proper reference point which is I don't
experience you to be a paranoid person
not at all so first let me just say the
first thing you need is to get your own
server which is as simple as five
dollars a month if you go to there's a
company I recommend called vulture.com
but it's spelled v
u l t r.com I'm going to use some
branding help but yeah so they have
something called Cloud compute for five
dollars a month
where basically that's setting up a
private slice it's just yours but on a
shared computer this is like a virtual
private server virtual private server
exactly I was trying to knock it
technically yeah um so and a server for
people who don't know I know this is
going to be old news for a lot of folks
what is the server sounds super
complicated it's just a computer that's
always online got it that's it okay
publicly accessible always online
doesn't even necessarily need to be
public we'll get to that because I think
for setting up your server there are
three options either the five dollars a
month vulture.com
Cloud compute number two search the web
for cloud compute for cheap dedicated
server so now a dedicated server is an
actual piece of Hardware that is only
yours not shared with anybody else so if
you want more privacy just spend a
little extra money and get a dedicated
server which means yeah this physical
Hardware
you're the only person that has access
they have physical access to it but you
have the only root password and it's
going to be an encrypted hard drive
we'll get to that
the third option is go to any used
Marketplace and find an old used Lenovo
ThinkPad ideally from the T400 series
you can get these for under 200 now and
they're great and they run any old
operating system and you would just set
this up in your closet and keep the
master version of your server in your
closet and then the other things would
be mirrors of that but we'll get to that
in a second
okay so here comes my you have done some
work good so yeah here's my quick how-to
and I'm going to tell you a few things
here that
aren't complete instructions but they're
enough for you to search the web so I'll
tell you what to do and you can search
the web for exactly how
the first thing you're going to need to
do is to use the terminal so the command
line in the Mac it's built in you go
into utilities folder it's called
terminal on Windows it's called
Powershell and anybody using Linux you
know what it is so the operating system
I'm going to recommend the one I use is
called openbsd and we touched on this on
the street the other night the reason I
use openbsd Sado masochism
Berkeley software distribution I was
born in Berkeley California and kind of
like more people named Dennis go into
Dentistry because there's an affiliation
of names Freakonomics pointed that out I
always wonder if my Affinity with the
BSD operating systems is because I was
born in Berkeley
anyway but the reason I got turned on to
openbsd is because I used to have Linux
server as a public server and it was
hacked one day and the guy at the data
center said uh yeah that's been
happening a lot lately he said you might
want to switch to BSD it's a lot more
secure so openbsd is designed for my the
ground up by super security Freaks and
part of why it's so secure is it's so
simple it's a very very simple operating
system that doesn't do everything under
the sun it does this that I'm describing
and it does it really well and it's
secure as hell and it's got as I
understand it few lines of code yes
right which means let's just say you're
a writer the more you write the higher
the frequency of typos yes don't want
bugs yes in your code that could be
exploited the less code the better so
install openvsd and follow the
instructions to encrypt one of the disk
partitions in there as you're installing
it then you're going to use SSH which
stands for secure shell to log into it
then on your home computer use that
terminal to generate a private SSH key
you do SSH Keygen the type you want is
Ed 25519
and then that's going to generate two
keys a private key and a public key you
upload the public key to your server and
then after you do that
edit your SSH configuration file to
disable password logins so now the only
way to log into your server is with your
private public key that you just
generated right very similar to the
crypto public private thing
then you go into your pf.com settings
you edit your firewall to only allow
Port 22 which is the port that SSH uses
to connect once you've done that voila
like now your server is super secure
nobody can get in except you from your
computer to the generated private key
through SSH is the only way to connect
to that server can you explain the
generated private key yeah it's really
just a single command you type on the
terminal if you type SSH Keygen space
Dash t space ed25519
it will ask you for an optional password
and it just creates the private key and
the public key same name but one has the
dot pub at the end and then you just use
whatever tool you want to upload the dot
Pub to your remote server and put it in
the correct place an authorized Keys
file and voila now
it will instead of asking you for your
password it just uses the private key
and the public key matching has to let
you in got it so it's like Marco Polo
okay yeah Warren as opposed to entering
a password every time right and that's
why then you want to change the SSH
server configuration files to disable
passwords so even if a billion script
kitties were trying to hack your server
to guess your password passwords are
just disabled keep track where you are
yeah do you think this will become and
I'm non-technical folks you've probably
guessed but this type of Marco Polo I'm
not gonna remember the proper way the
private keys and so on private public
keys or whatever determines will become
more and more prevalent as say Quantum
Computing and so on allows
the current level of encryption to be
decrypted more and more effectively I'm
just just wondering about well this is
going to take us off on a major change
what our phones are already doing behind
the scenes with WhatsApp encrypted chats
or FaceTime or even just our phones
themselves when you type in that code
when you first turn on your phone I
think our phones are already behind the
scenes using public private key yeah so
that's the way it should be it's just it
is the best solution so far I think yeah
a side note if you have four digit
password on your phone you can change
that to eight digit simple simple
upgrade yeah in the settings okay so
next thing you need a domain name my
recommended place to get a domain name
is a wonderfully nerdy non-commercial
site called bookmyname.com
you don't get 10 Affiliates absolutely
not wait till you see the site it's like
a wonderful old school nerdy there's no
affiliate program there as a backup I
use netim.com both of these are French
companies okay and there's a third one
in Portland Oregon that I like called
porkbun.com yeah all three of these are
really good reputable places to get a
domain name I recommend them no
affiliate fees at all I just like them I
use them okay so now you've got a server
and
the best thing to start with like you
said I'm not a guy that's got stockpiles
of oatmeal and gold
but once you've got I don't know why you
picked oatmeal but once you hello
once you've got your own server it puts
everything else into perspective so
that's really where I'm coming from when
I say like I don't do things in the
cloud it's because
when companies come out and say we can
take care of this for you yeah yeah it's
like you've already got in your your
bread and peanut butter and jam in the
kitchen and somebody says we can make a
sandwich for you in your own home you
think I don't need your help so for
those who heard the scotch really just
had me because Lord that was not very
much but you'll have extra personality
for this episode folks so for those
people who listen to what you just said
and they're like I think I just heard a
lot of Klingon I'm not sure but I can't
parse what any of that means it sounds
overwhelming right what would you say to
them I care about this so much that I'm
gonna set up
a really dead simple thing that's
basically just
do this copy paste this this is going to
work look at that so email me God damn
it email you write a blog post Derek so
everyone else
blog post what's that